oh my God I got shut down so bad by this
[__] old dude oh my God I was at this
coffee shop and I was killing it with
the small talk I was in a great mood you
know there was this guy in the corner
he's playing that game here you throw
the dice and then you move the checkers
up and down as they're black and white
and he looked like he wanted to be alone
right so my wife you know she comes over
and I go look at that over there Jesus
Christ guys got some goddamn issues
steering clear of him and she goes you
know he would probably like nothing
better than if you went over and said
hello to him and I was like really I
don't think so but I am kind of
fascinated with that game right and you
know me I got nothing else I got nothing
else to give me a buzz in life so I say
I'm getting another one so I go in there
I make some small talk with this lady
and I come walking I'm like you know I'm
gonna walk up to that angry guy who's
clearly saying don't walk up to me
because my wife's going like you know
what he'd probably enjoy it and I walked
up I go hey man what is that how do you
how do you play that game the guy just
without even look up just put his hand
up he goes sir please
I'm enjoying my alone time